you
[Music]
so the summary is that we we decided
last year to create a not-for-profit
development group to to work on the
Apache aero project which I will tell
you about there's a number of reasons
why we decided to do this partly because
the the aero project does involve the
our world but it involves the Python
world and many other programming
language ecosystems and we wanted to be
able to build relationships in with many
different companies around the world
that want data science tools to become
faster and more scalable into the future
so so Hadley and I are the you know the
leadership for the you know for the
organization we are now five full-time
engineers so we've got three people in
North America two people two people in
Europe so band and Friends far here so
if you see them please say hello folks
from the tidy verse team are are
involved on a part-time basis to work on
the our side of things we are still
hiring so if you know anyone who likes
to work on database systems or likes to
do benchmarking and tests and build
automation we have a lot of that to do
so please please definitely get in touch
so you know as treif was saying as
keynote earlier today you know our
studio has been it's been really really
amazing and helping helping us get this
off the ground by essentially you know
making it so that I don't have the
overhead of having to run a company can
focus on doing software engineering I
used to work at 2 Sigma they're
continuing to sponsor the work and we've
had Nvidia and also the open data
science conference join as sponsors for
2019 so Nvidia just gave us some really
high-end hardware to do testing for for
the software so that's been great so the
executive summary of like what this is
all about is that if you look at how
data science tools work now like base
our
you know numpy CyHi the Python ecosystem
MATLAB a lot of the semantics of how
these tools work are based on the way
that computational systems worked in the
1980s and 1990s
so everything's built on a foundation of
30 to 40 year old Fortran code you know
we we have seen tools you know augmented
with you know multi-core algorithms and
some more you know more sophisticated
execution but in general you have things
that are single core that out that
evaluate eagerly the language ecosystems
are pretty fragmented so you very rarely
see our programmers collaborating with
Python programmers and sharing libraries
of code to power their power their
applications so so the world that I
would like to see is to be able to take
advantage of all of this fancy hardware
that we have now we have graphics cards
we have computers you can buy a desktop
with 16 physical cores and 32 virtual
cores so you should be able to take
advantage of that we can compile code at
runtime and generate custom functions
that are specialized for your hardware
but a big part also is that I would like
to see the language ecosystems able to
collaborate and share code and data so
one one reason that not as much of this
work has happened happened yet has been
because of Moore's law and you know if
your code runs slow you can just wait
because in a couple of years your
processor will be twice as fast and that
is essentially stopped happening so we
need to get more out of the hardware
that we that we have because it's not
getting that much faster
year over year although we do have
graphics cards which seemingly are you
know continuing to scale and have
thousands of cores on a single single
graphics card so the Aero project so I
helped launch the project about three
years ago and our central ideas that
we'd wanted to define a language
language independent open standard for
data frames and you might say well we
have data frames and our and data frames
in Python but if you look under the hood
how the
those data frames are implemented how
they are arranged in memory they the
memory representation is very different
and so as a result of that you can't
really share code and if you want to
share data from one runtime environment
to another you have to serialize which
is very expensive so essentially the the
view of the world that we would like to
see is to have tools able to collaborate
and work on a common data representation
that is not tied to a particular runtime
environment or programming language so
kind of at the bird's eye view if you
think and where the the project is going
and since I have zero time now but we
what I you know what I would like to do
and what we've the way that we've been
building the community is to bring
together the data science world with the
analytic database communities so a lot
of the performance and scalability work
in working with Big Data I don't know if
we're still saying big data now as has a
lot of that work has happened in the
analytic database world and relatively
little work has made its way into the
data science ecosystem and if you look
at the way that database engines are
built typically you interact with them
through sequel or some other front-end
api usually it's usually it's SQL
queries but those queries then interact
with a bunch of components that deal
with query execution in memory data
management and interactions with storage
and essentially you know whether it's
disk or cloud storage or whatever so so
what we were doing in the Aero project
is building a set of high quality
components that have public api's that
can be used as the basis of building
different kinds of essentially embedded
database engines that can be run on a
laptop or run kind of in a distributed
cluster but we aren't really being
prescriptive about the front end so if
you want to build a database you can
build a database if you want to build a
dataframe library or build something
that can be used by an R or Python
programmer you can do that as well
so we have three primary use cases and
I'm going to tell you very briefly about
how this is relevant to our programmers
but the three the three big things that
we're concerned with is getting faster
access to data so being able to read and
write data sets in the most important
file formats as fast as possible we want
to be able to move around data as
efficiently as possible within a single
node so between one process and another
through shared memory or moving data
between nodes in a in a network through
remote procedure calls so through
sockets or other internode communication
the last so the last thing is that we
want to be able to compute analytics and
so if you're using our using Python
you're already doing analytics every day
when you use data frame libraries so
these would be standardized libraries of
algorithms that can be used in many
different many different scenarios and
we want to be able to take advantage of
the latest and greatest in compiler
technology to be able to do
specialization of functions to go even
faster based on prior knowledge of what
you're doing with your data so how is
this all relevant to our well we we are
building bindings for the arrow
libraries which are mostly written in
C++ so that work on the our side has
been been led led by our man Francois
who's you may know from the the deep
liar project so I will talk about our
data frames because I have enough time
but the the key use cases where there's
a lot of interest in the our world is
being able to memory map and interact
with very large on disk datasets that
don't fit into memory we want to be able
to this is not about replacing deep wire
or replacing data table it's about
having tools that can be used to
accelerate these projects while leaving
the user interface like with a code that
you write largely largely unchanged so
if you may know about deep wire deep
liar
is already a domain-specific language
where you write a sequence of deep wire
verbs and expressions and then those
expressions are effectively compiled
into whatever back-end where deep liar
is executing so deep liar can execute
and it's against sequel engines or it
can execute using it's in memory it's in
memory engine and so what our goal is to
do is if you do have a very large data
set which is coming out of code in the
aro ecosystem whether it's memory mapped
on disk data or maybe you have a
directory of park' files or you know
maybe a set of you know cloud buckets
that contain park' files so using deep
liar you may have a narrow data set and
a collection of deep liar verbs and so
we can translate these standard deep
liar expressions into computation graphs
that are evaluated by parallel runtime
coming out of the aero project and we
can also do fancy things like look at
non-standard evaluation kind of unev
alyou ated our expressions so when you
write this and deploy these expressions
don't get evaluated immediately but we
can do use LLVM to compile these these
expressions to go even faster against
against the data sets so anyway I'm
sorry about the AV problems but you know
these things these things happen but
anyway there's there's a lot of
interesting things on the horizon for
the project and I'm excited to
collaborate with the arc community
getting the software in in production
and making you're making your data
science work faster and more more
efficient and hopefully a little bit a
little bit more fun so many of you may
be aware about three years ago we
started the hadley and I started the
feather project which uses the arrow
technology internally so another thing
we'd like to see is a an evolved version
of feather that has more features and is
faster and more efficient than what is
the one is there now so even if you're
already a feather user I mean even that
we'll be we'll be improved eventually so
anyway check out the slides and I'll be
around the conference if you'd like to
if you'd like to chat thank you
[Music]